من بيروت ناجي ملاعب الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي سد ناجي اهلا وسهلا
معك عند هذه الخطوه الجديده وهذا الدعم
الامريكي الاضافي والاعلان عن تزويد
اوكرانيا بذخائر اليورانيوم المنظم هل
تحدث تغييرا بالتالي في هذا الهجوم
الاوكراني كما قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه قال ان هذه النوعيه من الاسلحه
قد تعطي زخما
للهجوم ما رايك
يبدو حتى الان ان هذه القذائف التي ستتزوج
بها الدباباتي لابرامز عنوان ايوان وهذه
الدبابات وصل منها الى المانيا بين سته
وثمان دبابات فقط لعدد تاهيلها وكل ما هو
منتظر هو 30 دبابه من هون لحد راس السنه
يعني هذا الموضوع استخدامه في تلك
الدبابات يعني امد طويل يعني اعطي حيز
اعلامي اكثر مما هو على الارض قد يحدث
فرقا حاليا لان التدرب على تلك الدبابات
وحسن استخدامها يبدا لا اقل من مطلع
الشتاء المقبل هذا واحد اثنين الحزمه التي
ورد بها الاوكرانيون لا شك انها ممكن ان
تحدث فرقا لان تزويدها بدخائر
155 وقذائف الميه
وكل ذلك
لدعم الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الهجوم حتى
اليوم يعني لم يعني رغم كل
الانتظار العالمي ان سوف يحدث فرقا ما زال
الاوكران يحاولون
الهجمات تلو الهجمات يوميا حتى الشمال وفي
الجنوب يعني هذا الهجوم لم يفطر حتى الان
وبالتالي دعمه ممكن ان يحدث فرقا اكثر شيء
منتظر ان يكون الفرق ما بين في فيروجيا
وباتجاه
ميليتيبول في الجنوب يعني هذا الاساس الذي
يحاول اوكرانيون اختراقه يمكن ان اذا ما
حصل وتمكنوا من الوصول الى الى الساحل
ممكن ان يعزلوا شبه جزيره القرم يعني هناك
اذا ما دعم الاوكران ببعض التقنيات
الحديثه الحديثه ممكن ان يحدث فرقا اكثر
من الذخائر المنظبه
باليورانيوم والمنظم طيب استاذ نجم ملاعب
حلف شمال الاطلسي يتحدث اليوم عن تقدم في
هذا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد سمعنا في
الاونه الاخيره هذه الانتقادات لهذا
الهجوم غير
المنسقه كما قيل بالتالي ربما هذه الخطوه
الامريكيه تاتي في توقيت مهمه للغايه هل
نتوقع مزيد من الدعم العسكري الامريكي
هناك مزيد من الدعم متواصل كل اسبوع
اسبوعين يعلن عن دعم جديد امريكي وبالتالي
هناك نوع من تغيير استراتيجي بالخطط في
داخل اوكرانيا راينا تغيير وزير الدفاع
واجتماع الرئيسكي بالقاده العسكريين يبدو
ان هناك استراتيجيات جديده طبعا لن تكون
تلك استراتيجيات نافعه لم تكن مدعومه
بتقنيات حديثه كما قلت لك وبانتظار نوع من
تغيير في الحالات هناك منذ ادار منذ مارس
هناك التدرب على الطائرات 16 هناك اقتراب
ممكن ان يكون طائرات ل 16 ممكن ان تكون
بدات تجهيزها باتجاه ان تكون هناك استخدام
انشاء غطاء جهوي مهم كثير لاوكرانيا في
هذا الاتجاه يمنع التفوق الروسي في اوكر
انيا وبالتالي نحن امام استعدادات كبيره
لدعم الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد شكرا جزيلا
لك
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي حدثنا من بي